[Music]
this morning on the dish one of
Britain's most renowned middle-eastern
chefs born and raised in Jerusalem Yotam
or leggy served in the Israeli army and
got a degree in comparative literature
before turning his attention to food
after cooking school in London he teamed
up with his partners to found his
namesake restaurant Auto langauge
delicatessen where inventive vegetable
dishes and gorgeous baked goods are the
star attraction they quickly gained a
cult following and led to five other
restaurants
he's written seven cookbooks two of
which have one James Beard Awards and
his latest auto leggy simple came out
just last week Sheffield Tom Auto lanky
welcome to the dish good to be here yes
guys this is a feast it looks
spectacular it's what you get this
season you know it's like it's like
Thanksgiving Christmas and so the main
thing is the roast chicken to big roast
chicken and it's got a really wonderful
stuffing made with sour dough yeah
moist moist yeah it is all about that
and then the sides our roasted butternut
squash with lentils dal cheela ten tons
of herbs there is broccoli and kale with
fried garlic and cumin roasted
cauliflower and raw cauliflower salad
with pomegranate and pistachios and this
delightful little oh and that's a
coriander or cilantro as you say here so
you say you had a self-professed you say
yourself that you were a happy kid I was
what made that so and did the kitchen
have anything to do with it
well to be honest I mean I've just I
grew up in Jerusalem so they mean the
food as you know in that part of the
world is just phenomenal and I've you
know lots of vegetables everywhere and
you know Arabic food as you know it the
homeless and the falafel another race
and so I was really lucky to have been
exposed to all these flavors from
childhood that I loved I want I loved
eating
[Laughter]
I went to university and realized that
actually I won't cook myself nobody will
cook for me you know that I think that's
the realization that every student has
when they when they when they leave home
so I just started cooking and having
people over entertaining and the nice
thing about cooking is that I love three
elements of cooking shopping for
ingredients yeah cooking and then
serving because you get all these
incredible feedbacks I mean it's you
serve a good meal well and University
you had your master's degree in
philosophy your parents come from this
academic background how did you tell
them that you knew that you needed to go
into the world of could that was a bit
painful so I had my dissertation
laughter I finished studying at
University I sent it I sent it through
the post as that you did in the 90s so
my parents I was living in Europe at the
time and inside there was a little note
when hey there you go there's my
dissertation I finished my degrees but
actually not taking time off and I'm
going to learn how to cook didn't go
down very well so my you know my dad is
you know he's the gentlest nicest person
he said to me I don't know if that's
advisable his mind since he has changed
his mind yet I mean you know he's had
quite a few years to get used to the
idea and he'd seen what I've created and
how much joy I'm getting out of it but
in the beginning you described yourself
as an oddball in the kitchen mm-hmm and
you almost quit yeah kitchens are just
hard yes you know it's like it's it's
like being it's very regimented there's
a lot of shouting and screaming going on
you need to get all the food out on time
so if you are you know slightly don't
fit in it's difficult so yeah almost
left but then I discovered that I could
choose my own place so I could look I
found places that I really enjoyed
working at and that's what I always tell
young young Chefs these days don't work
where you don't want like to work
working good restaurants where you're
being respected in you and you enjoy
going to work in the morning otherwise
kind of what's the point and you have to
respect yourself I love that I love
everything about you Tom but as we
finish up our meal and our drink I would
love for you to sign the dish and think
about if there's any one person that you
would love to share this meal with okay
so I there's a argentinian chef called
francis Norman he looks yeah he's from
Patagonia down south and he does
incredible things on a barbecue and
grill I've only seen him once let met
him once for like three minutes that's
the person I would love to have Wow I
love it well so you know Tom I'm telling
you we appreciate you coming with us
you're so awesome and for more on the
chef and his fabulous dish ours as well
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com